[Musik]
und 2
ich bin heute in raster wo eine
politische weltkarriere startete die
ihresgleichen sucht die rede ist von
hubert aiwanger
oder wie freunde ihn nennen derivate und
wo ist er jetzt was machen wir dann hier
freunde bitten
hallo hallo freut mich herzlich
willkommen im wirtschaftsministerium ja
ich freue mich hier zu sein freut mich
dass sie da sind politiker wie sie
findet man ja heutzutage gar nicht mehr
sind sie so was wie der yeti der politik
und wird er dann gerne auf das ländliche
reduziert mit bürgerlichem hintergrund
der schaut man gerne von oben runter
aber ich glaube dass mir dieser ganze
gute erdung gegeben hat von klein auf
ein bauernhof mitzuarbeiten mit tieren
umzugehen verantwortung zu übernehmen
am sonntagvormittag in andere
ausschlafen konnten musstest du dich um
die tiere kümmern und muss eben alles zu
ende denken und das hat mich eigentlich
fürs leben geprägt volksnahe noch nicht
so ich sag mal wenn ich mir herrn söder
angucke der seine instagram post alle
durch plant ja ich mache auch meine
instagram verlust und man hofft
natürlich bei jedem platz aus um
irgendwo eine vernünftige reaktion hat
das glauben sie warum sind politiker wie
sie seltener weil es immer schwerer ist
mit ecken und kanten und mit eigener
meinung in einer mainstream welt zu
überleben politisch weil man immer mehr
beschossen wird bin ein bisschen aus der
reihe tanzt die freien wähler stehen den
aktuellen umfragen bei fünf prozent
das heißt sie vereinen das talent der
spd von regierungsarbeit nicht zu
profitieren mit den umfragewerten der
fdp herr z
unsere stärke ist natürlich kurz vor der
wahl wieder mit unseren regionalen
schwergewichten ins spiel zu kommen
dann wird man wieder gewählt also die
basis ist gesund aber die große
bundespolitische bühne haben wir eben
noch nicht mit ausnahme von heute 7
jetzt geht es steil bergauf eigentlich
hoffe man sagt ja offen dass die
stellvertreter die wahren strategen
hinter ihren chef sind kann man sagen
sie sind das hören von markus söder
zumindest der bislang sein schlechtes
gewissen also ich schau wird die dinge
alle nochmal drüber und hole viele dinge
dann doch wieder runter auf den boden
der tatsachen und sagt bitte den ton mit
rüber nach zu ende gedacht hat dass
andere wirkungen
also jetzt häufig vielleicht etwas
impulsiver und ich bin vielleicht ein
bisschen dort ist ausgleichend
bodenständige element ich habe noch ein
best of ihrer aussagen vorbereitet ich
bin überzeugt bayern und deutschland wie
jeder anständige mord und wie die
anständige frau am nächsten der taschen
holten tür bild haben dürfte und wie
wird die schwerkriminellen der richtige
weg ich hätte vielleicht noch ein
alternativvorschlag dass wir das mit der
bewaffnung dieser dieser einen behörde
über das an der polizei das
taschenmesser an sich ist glaube ich
nicht das böse und ensi bayern ist
sicher wenn der anständigen
taschenmesser haben darf aber der
unanständige ins gefängnis kommt der
kriminelle und nicht der kriminelle mit
zehn straftaten und zehn
körperverletzungen frei rumläuft und man
dem opa sein taschenmesser arten im wald
zum pilze sammeln gehen will
das war die aussage gab es natürlich
auch eine geschichte aus der realität
genau meine damen und herren in meinen
augen soll niemand das abitur bekommen
wenn er keinen orgel in ein brett
schlagen kann würde ich nach wie vor
unterschreiben
wir haben ja deshalb auch mehr praxis
unter richtigen gymnasien eingeführt
habe ich mal gespannt ob sie auch ein
nagelbrett schlagen
ich habe natürlich noch mehr nägel ja
dann gucken wir mal ob nicht das
bayerische abitur auch bestehe
okay okay also habe ich bayerische
abitur sie brauchbar
also ich bin stolz auf diese werden
eingebürgert und alles was ich dafür tun
musste waren nagelbrett schlag genau so
einfach es ist also ich mag hier
und damit zurück ins studio
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye